I normally test the latest Beauty
releases but today I'm testing out the
most hyped products from the early 2000s
MAC lipsticks were so popular in the
2000s myth was like the concealer lip
shade it's this super pale nude that
looks ridiculous on me without a lip
liner and snob is this pale pastel pink
color that reminds me of Nicki Minaj
aside from the questionable color
choices the Mac satin lipstick formula
still holds up it's comfortable on the
lips and the formula is pretty buildable
doo-wop lip Venom is like the OG lip
plumper the tangle with this is pretty
strong so if you hate that feeling I
would avoid this I noticed the Plumping
more on my top lip but it definitely
plumps and I noticed that it also made
my lips look a bit smoother this is the
Mac lip liner in spice this lip liner
formula applies really smoothly it
doesn't dry down too quickly so you have
time to blend I tried to do a super
defined lip liner look with that myth
lipstick and I actually loved it I'm
definitely going to keep using this